what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so in light of the most recent
episode of the flash and only go know if
you guys have seen yet if you're not
watching the flash right now like you
are you are missing out it is it's the
best thing come out of DC we read it is
amazing and Candice Patton kind of woman
it's beautiful
um but it is it's really really good so
I figured because of what you know
recently happened that we would cover
the flash out of time story because
that's basically what they're using and
the flash TV show and so because of that
um there's a couple things that we sort
of need to line out here the first is
that this does not take place in DC
rebirth that is to say it doesn't take
place in the modern line of DC stories
this actually takes place in the new 52
specifically following the events up
forever evil now forever evil was a
story that dealt with the idea that the
crime syndicate of America basically the
Justice League from her three for the
evil version of the Justice League from
her three had invaded earth and just run
amok all over the place now at the time
if I remember correctly at the time
Barry Allen iris West
they were just kind of like totally
displaced from the main DC reality so
they couldn't actually be in Central
City but in their absence the crime
syndicate was just running amok all over
the planet earth they captured a lot of
members of the Justice League or
defeated them and so on and so there
wasn't really anybody to stand up to
them so Central City was one of the one
of the casualties of all their escapades
where you know they just engage in
criminal activities and tore things
apart now of course ultimately forever
evil concluded with lex luthor forming
his own superhero team composed of
villains and then fighting off in
defeating the crime syndicate of america
which of course as we know set the stage
for the new 52 lex luthor to become a
good guy as we know him now in action
comics and Superman from DC rebirth so
you guys got to see how it's just a
continuing trend that goes on from the
stories that were originally written but
the fact remains here that in the
greater scheme of things for every evil
serve the purpose of you know basically
leading into Darkseid war which in turn
led into DC rebirth so it was just kind
of a series of events that led us to
where we are right now but in terms of
the story this goes all the way back to
the new 52 flash so it's not really DC
rebirth stuff and in fact it'll set the
stage for a lot of things that come and
rebirth with regards to Wally West
getting his powers but initially this
opens up with very Alan basically
witnessing iris West crippled in a you
know from a car wreck and in Wally West
or Lanoue to to Wally West dead
now the funny thing about this is that
this actually deals with the
introduction of the new 52 Wally West
keep in mind back when this story was
written the red-haired Wally West simply
wasn't there it was just you know the
young african-american new 52 Wally West
and he was really the only one that we
got but we don't know what the events
were that led to this karlik all we know
is that it seems to have resulted in and
you know basically iris West being
crippled and and Wally West having been
killed now what we're going to do here
is we're going to largely focus on the
blue flash the future flash and the
reason why is because of the fact that
all that really happens here with
regards to the present day Barry Allen
if he gets in a different ESCA page and
he goes through different events and so
on and so forth but he ends up finding
himself behind that is to say you know
where he would leave I mean he'd be
faster than this but you know where he
would leave his house at like 110 and
use the you know useless flash powers
and expect to be somewhere at like one
you know 115 he'd actually get there at
117 essentially meaning that he's
slowing down and he doesn't quite know
why you know he doesn't know why it is
that he's slowing down
now the answer for why he's slowing down
comes from the future flash comes from
the blue flash and so that's what we're
going to focus on let's we're going to
kind of emphasize in this video but
jumping forward 20 years from now we
basically pick up with very Allen
himself and that's kind of the crazy
thing is because in the future he
basically looks back at everything
that's happened and says that he's
missed so much time and that's the crazy
thing about this is he is obsessed with
the fact that he's missed so many things
he's obsessed with the fact that there
were so many instances where he was just
getting slower and slowly now why he was
getting slower we don't know because
historically speaking when it comes to
the Speed Force flashes get faster they
don't get slower and so because of that
it means that somehow or another his
connection to the Speed Force is
diminishing and at this point 20 years
in the future it's as low as it's ever
going to be and so the idea that Barry
Allen has is to basically travel into
the past and begin the process of fixing
all his past mistakes now why fixing
these past mistakes is going to you know
allow him to become faster we don't know
and that won't really be explained until
we get towards the end of the story
but one of the first things he does is
he visits the grave of the new 52 Wally
West of course with Iris being there and
crippled now this is kind of cool
because technically in the new 52 in
terms of chronology this is the FIR
time that Barry Allen reveals his
identity to Iris West as the flash
that's one of the big differences you
know between what goes on right now
at least what happened in this story and
what's going on right now even in DC
rebirth and DC rebirths iris does not
know that that Barry Allen is the flash
Wally West just found out so again you
know in this future timeline he still
hadn't told them they still didn't know
now of course we know as the reader
Barry Allen never tells iris what you
know never tells iris what his identity
is because of the fact that if iris knew
and somebody found that she knew that it
would no longer be a circumstance of
warm just going to attack iris West
because she's a reporter now it becomes
a circumstance up I'm going to attack
iris West
and I'm not going to tell anybody where
she is because I'm going to torture her
for the information of who the flash
actually is and so because of that it
would put her in more danger than she
ever would have been in now in response
to iris learning that the identity of
the flash is Barry Allen it's a little
bit of a shock it's a little bit of kind
of you know being taken by surprise but
it's also very basically saying I'm
going to go back in time and I'm going
to fix things I'm going to correct my
mistakes every step of the way all the
things that he should have done that he
didn't do he's going to correct those
things now this is a combination of
actions half of it is just defeating
villains that would try to attack
central city and lay waste to it while
he's gone once they figure out that he's
gone the other half is actually going
through and just turning things around
you know fixing past issues and we'll
see those you know as we go through this
but the first person he encounters is
Gorilla Grodd now in the new 52 flash
issue number seven it was established
you know because of the fact that it was
a reboot it was established that the
individuals in gorilla city which is to
say were gorilla grodd hails from
basically have their enhanced attributes
from the Speed Force itself the
difference here is that Gorilla Grodd
during the events of forever evil had
actually ingested canisters of the Speed
Force directly and so the result was
that he basically had the ability to
move as fast as the flash now it wasn't
like a consistent thing I mean he could
do it depending on the circumstances you
know if he ingested it just kind of
bolstered his powers and that kind of a
saying but what this shows us is that in
the future Gorilla Grodd never lost the
Speed Force his connection is still
maintained and his ability to move at
super speed it still maintained now this
is kind of a funny thing about this is
because Gorilla Grodd had basically used
his powers of the flash to begin moving
all
the past the present and the future and
the reason why is because one he
basically eliminated every single person
every single being in gorilla City aside
from himself
- he began going through and grabbing
all these different historical texts in
order to bolster his own intelligence
and free he was eventually plotting for
domination you know dominion over the
earth and of course his powers would
have let him would have allowed him to
do that but with very Allen being here
his goal to basically eliminate Gorilla
Grodd is done for the sole purpose of
making sure that Grodd will not attack
central city or the earth while Barry
Allen isn't there now the problem with
this is there's no way for Barry Allen
to make sure this doesn't happen so long
as Grodd is alive because if brada is
for example trapped in the Speed Force
he'll be able to escape because he can
access the Flash's powers it's only a
matter of fitara figuring out how and so
because of this Barry Allen makes the
only decision that he can make here he
does the only thing that he can do in
the battle between himself and Gorilla
Grodd
he basically phases through Gorilla
Grodd or at least raises his hand
through his head plants the micro bomb
and blows his head up basically just
killing Gorilla Grodd now the reason why
then did Ian those guys gave us this
story the way they did is because it's
designed to show us the limits or the
lengths that this version this future
version of Barry Allen will go to in
order to keep things safe in order to
achieve his own mission he will kill
people and that's actually what he's
going to do with several individuals
he's going to basically kill him really
is only one other guy that he kills but
the fact remains here that he's going to
be willing to kill in order to make sure
that his goal is achieved and so because
of that we again basically pick up 16
years from the present day and that's
what we're going to do we're going to
kind of use the present day as an anchor
point so we're going to say like 16
years from now or 16 years from the
present day seven years from the
president five years from the present
day that kind of thing and so if we're
going to use use the current day as an
anchor point or at least the current day
within this story as an anchor point ed
were to show us you know what we have so
we don't literally get lost in time as
we're going through the story but the
fact remains here that that with regards
to the future flash showing up you know
16 years from the present day he's
actually encountering mirror master and
this is one of those instances where
he's basically going through and he's
trying to make sure that he can you know
he can prevent these past events from
happening he can save lives now the
funny thing about this is that this does
not inherently
fix his ability or fix what's going on
with the Speed Force all it's really
doing is just kind of soothing his own
guilt that's really
I am just kind of going through fixing
things like this for the sole purpose of
making himself feel better of correcting
his past mistakes and it works because
we've all had a litany of instances
where we screwed things up but we kind
of wish you could go back and fix it not
because it would change the future but
because of the fact that it just
wouldn't weigh on our minds anymore and
so what we end up finding out here is
that what mirror master launching in
this campaign you know and watching this
attack but of course he's basically
imprisoning people and mirrors and
different things like that but
ultimately what it happened is that from
Barry Allen's perspective him coming
from four years after this particular
instance had taken place you know coming
from the future he basically tells
mirror master where I'm from in my time
your campaign is a complete and total
failure and the reason why is because of
the fact that all these people being
stuck in mirrors isn't necessarily a bad
thing I mean your ability is mirror
master is to make mirrors you know
transform them from one-way mirrors into
two-way mirrors so you can walk in and
walk out but by traveling all the people
in here and then holding them hostage a
freak earthquake is going to come
through and it's going to shatter all
these mirrors and these people are going
to be dead and lost forever and so
because of that it's kind of wild in
this sense that is basically Barry
saying hey look you're going to become a
murderer now the reason why this matters
is because of the fact that remember in
the flash landscape the roads are not
killers they do not kill it's like the
one rule they have the robbed they'll
hold people hostage but at the end of
the day somebody will call their bluff
if it comes down to it and the Rogues
you're like sitting in a room and
they're holding somebody hostage and the
cops say okay fine well then kill them
the Rogues aren't going to do it like
they're not going to kill they'll just
try to find a way to escape and that'll
really be in and that's one of the
reasons why Barry Allen despite being an
enemy of them still respects them
because of the fact that they just
really won't kill in the midst of all
this what is up happening is Barry Allen
basically says look here's what's going
to happen you're going to become a
killer you're going to become a murderer
because of the fact that you just
executed the wrong campaign at the wrong
time and so you know again mirror master
more or less turns around mirror master
basically allows all these individuals
to leave so he won't be branded as a
killer and in the end you know the
earthquake rolls through and mayor
masters just kind of the seized by all
of his own mirrors and the implication
seems to be here that mirror master
actually dies now if something's
explicitly kind of shown to us that
seems to be the case she's just kind of
covered in shards of his own mirrors and
so on and so forth but that's really
what Barry Allen's doing it's just kind
of going through and fixing issues with
no concern for what actually happens to
the bad guy you know the next person
that he ends up visiting is actually
captain Cole now the crazy thing about
captain
cold is right now this was 12 years from
the present day captain cold has
basically died and it's really kind of a
funny situation with regards to Barry
Allen talking to a mr. flash talking to
talking to captain Cole because what
he's basically saying is look we thought
for so long and the fact that you're
dying is me just kind of saying my final
goodbyes but it's also him giving us a
little bit of information with regards
to what it is he's doing and what we
find out here is there is a wound in the
speedforce there is a tear in the
speedforce how it got there we don't
quite know yet but we simply know that
it's there and the goal of Barry Allen
is to travel into the past in order to
go to the point at which that tear first
formed and then fill it or keep it from
tearing you know keep it from opening
any further now again it's really kind
of interesting here because he's
basically kind of saying saying his
goodbyes to a villain that he respects
and that's one of the important aspects
of the the Rogues that's maintained
throughout almost all versions of DC
Comics for example in injustice Batman
basically allies himself with the Rogues
because of the fact that the Rogues
don't kill following the death of
trickster you know at the hands of a
bizarro even though it's kind of an
accident you know when bizarro dropped
him onto the side of a cliff and the
robes are kind of getting together you
know when they're they're sort of
mourning him and they're mourning the
other members of the Rogues who were
basically killed you know when bizarro
went crazy and fried them all with his
heat vision Barry Allen sits down with
them and says look the one thing I
always respected about you guys is that
you never killed so it's one of the
things that's always kind of maintained
with the rope and so because of that
it's one of these things where it's
Barry Allen paying his respects to a guy
who never killed the two of them always
battled one another and despite the fact
that happening cold was a villain he
always pushed very to his height she
always pushed him to run faster run
harder and become more capable now
picking up with the trickster this is
where things get a little bit crazy and
the reason why is because of the fact
that trickster is actually going to
execute a plan whereby he's going to
steal a safe and his robots are going to
carry it off remember trickster uses
like these different little gadgets and
different things like that but the fact
remains here that he had his own little
scheme with robots who were going to
allow him to basically rob a bank and
these robots were going to carry us safe
to a pre-loaded destination where he was
going to be able to open it up and take
all the jewels and the money for himself
the issue with this is that the way the
event plays out is that the robots are
not capable of carrying the safe and so
in mid-flight the robots basically end
up failing to save Falls in a
land on a mother a father in a one-year
of one month old baby and so because of
that this is Barry Allen going back into
the past in order to basically stop this
event from happening to stop the
trickster now at the outset the
implication seems to be that he's
actually going to let the trickster fall
to his death that he's going to let the
trickster die and that's really going to
be yet that he's going to just kind of
let him go away you know he's going to
help him be finished with with all of
his livings but again it really shows us
kind of the brutal nature of what he was
willing to do now ultimately he doesn't
ultimately he doesn't kill the trickster
he just basically says hey look here's
what was going to happen with regards to
what it was that you did now with a
trickster face for the fact that he was
inadvertently going to murder a family
he turns over he basically walks away
and says look here's here's the key to
all the gadgets and everything that I
have and again this is really kind of
tying into the nature of the road the
roads don't kill the roads execute their
own schemes without loss of life if at
all possible and so what we do is we
kind of get this one-page splash where
you know future flash is just sort of
running continuing back into the past
you know it's seven years from the
present day six years from the present
day you know and then five and a half
years from the present day so again as
these different campaigns that have been
stalked by different members of the
roads or these major events ease major
you know instances where people were
killed and like a fire or something like
that and it's one of those things that
just kind of wait on his mind and he
never quite had Tommy you never had the
ability to get there in time because his
connection to the Speed Force was
dwindling and so because of this what it
does is it basically jumps to the moment
when the new 52 Wally West and iris West
were supposed to die in this car crash
and what we end up finding out is that
the car crash was basically initiated by
Daniel West now of course Daniel West
was the newest iteration of the
reverse-flash and a lot of fans didn't
really like him I mean they wanted to be
the classic eobard thawne back and of
course we had these great big huge
discussions about reverse-flash but you
know to give you guys kind of a quick
rundown here Daniel West was a guy who
experienced a really abusive situation
with his father but it also drove drove
a win rift between himself and iris and
so because of this Daniel basically want
to just kind of go back into the past
and change his own history change his
own story about his father being as you
know being as abusive as he was and even
killing him so again it's very similar
to the history of Barry Allen in terms
of the fact that Daniel West and Barry
Allen were both on a collision course to
lose their signature you know
their parents yeah lose those
significant individuals in their family
now of course this eventually led to him
kind of falling down the rabbit hole
becoming a bad guy dubbing himself the
reverse-flash and becoming a villain of
baryons and that's usually how it goes
when it comes to the reverse-flash
concept somebody gains the powers of the
Speed Force they have a goal in mind
they become corrupted by their power or
their own goal and they eventually
become an enemy of the flash it's pretty
cut and dry in terms of how those
stories unfold but the fact remains here
that daniel west had been caught by
Barry Allen had been incarcerated in
iron Heights and then eventually was
freed and so what ended up happening
here is he basically went on a mission
to try to either intercept iris and
Wally or at the very least engage in a
skirmish with the flash the issue here
is that when the car wreck was supposed
to happen future flash shows up just in
time to prevent it from happening to
prevent this car accident from taking
place and so what is up happening here
is that as he's facing off against
against Daniel West keep in mind
Daniel West is still relatively new and
still pretty untrained in terms of how
to use the Speed Force adequately he's
nowhere near the original eobard thawne
and so because of this Daniel West is
woefully ill-equipped to go against the
flash it gonna give you no future Barry
Allen and he's easily overpowered the
problem with this is that in the
conflict he's able to basically vibrate
himself and in Daniel West so that the
vehicle passes directly through them and
in the end decapitates Daniel killing
him in the process now because the fact
that this is five and a half years from
the present day what it does is it shows
us a totally different set of events now
for those of you guys who were reading
DC rebirth what happened is that this
basically changes things in its entirety
towards DC rebirth in the sense that new
v2 to Wally West is actually going to
get flash powers because of the events
as they unfold here in the end what ends
up happening is because of the fact that
Daniel and iris witnessed the future
flash killing you know Daniel west and
because of the fact that Barry Allen
shows up I guess you know present-day
Barry Allen shows up just in time you
know and under normal circumstances
would have shown up after they had
already died in the crash the two you
know both Barry Allen and future flash
get into a fight with one another now
the scorm is the skirmish is pretty
short it's pretty quick in the end you
know future flash is able to get the
upper hand quick fast and in a hurry but
what ends up happening is Barry Allen
basically creates a feedback loop
between the two of them now
a little bit like ambiguous really in
terms of in terms of how it's given to
us by rubber Venditti
there's not a whole lot of exposition
here the only thing we're really given
is the idea that this part of fact this
is all five and a half years in the
future Barry Allen is not supposed to be
in the same place at the same time for
whatever reason that's just not supposed
to happen we're not really told why
we're not given a reason it's almost
like if you were to take two two magnets
and you were to put them against each
other you know they'd have a reverse
polarity and they would try to push each
other away and so because of that you
know basically Crais is kind of feedback
and in future flash it sort of just kind
of dissipated out through time now of
course this results in in the new 52
wally west running to the aid of barry
allen only to in turn gain speed force
powers himself and that's why i say this
kind of all gets retcon and all gets
changed up because of the story because
as we know right now in DC rebirth
there's basically an electrical storm
that takes place in the in the flash
landscape you know and the result is
that wally west gets his powers that way
and so because of that what is up
happening here is that in the confines
of this particular story barry allen
basically tells Wally you now have the
powers of the flash and this future
flash is going to keep coming back
that's what flashes do they always come
back he's messing with the time stream
your job now is to go find this guy and
try to see if you can bring his campaign
of evil to an end and so what ends up
happening here is the future flash is
basically thrown into the present day
and while all this is going on the new
52 Wally West from the future is now
running back and forth through time
trying to stop the future flash now we
don't see a lot of those we don't really
see very many instances of that
happening instead all we know is that in
different occasions they've been facing
off against one another that the fact
that we're not seeing that it's done for
the purpose of keeping a story from
being very confusing because if we had
that going on right now like if we had
these events taking place right here and
then future Wally West's going against
future Barry Allen it would cause all
kinds of different continuity problems
and it would confuse the absolute heck
out of the reader and so what Venditti
does is he brings all these different
themes to ahead and he finally shows us
what's going on and what we end up
learning here is that because of the
fact that over the course of the new 52
iris west got flash powers and Gorilla
Grodd got flash powers and Daniel West
got flash
and all those individuals kept running
in and out of the speedforce and they
kept traveling back and forth through
time what they basically did is they
began to eat away and began to tear away
at the speed for so it would be like if
I sat down a piece of cheese and
everybody just kind of started grabbing
little bits here and there eventually
it's just going to be kind of a mangled
chunk of the thing
and so because of that that's basically
what's happening with the speed force
the speed force you know while it is a
wildly powerful source of energy it can
be abused it can be ruined it can be
tainted it can be tainted by individuals
who all begin accessing its power and
who do not exist in a delicate balance
and that's really kind of the way the
Speed Force is supposed to function that
in this particular moment there's only
really supposed to be a singular flash
which is very out you know even if there
was more than one flash it has to exist
in a balance they shouldn't be abusing
the Speed Force running in and out of it
all the time really just kind of ruining
it and tearing it apart and so again
while it is a little bit ambiguous here
well there isn't is you know isn't
really a play-by-play of exactly what it
is that caused all this the implication
seems to be that because so many people
got flash powers because so many people
were running in and out of the Speed
Force that it caused different problems
with the Speed Force itself so the
result here is that we end up having
this conflict directly between the
current day Barry Allen at the time of
this story and the future Barry Allen at
the time of this story now the fight
between them is really kind of
interesting and the reason why is
because of the fact the future flash
coming back here is basically designed
for the purpose of killing his younger
self and then dispersing those energies
into the Speed Force and fixing it so it
would be like if you punched a hole in
the wall and then you just grabbed you
know some material and patched the hole
that's exactly what it is that future
flash is trying to do he's trying to
take the energy of Barry Allen and throw
it into the Speed Force and fix this
tear and the Speed Force the issue with
this is that it creates a couple of
continuity issues or at least it seems
to create continuity issues on the
surface one thing to point out here is
that individuals who are tied to the
Speed Force can basically exist outside
of space and time and so because of that
while future Barry is trying to kill his
younger self paradox will not exist here
it will not take place here he exists
outside of time you know under normal
circumstances we would say well if all
the things that he's done led up to this
future version of himself and then he
went back and he fixed all those things
would mistreat yourself cease to exist
so it's the events that led to him
becoming
that way don't exist anymore that's not
the case it's the reason why a Abarth on
the reverse-flash is able to exist
outside of space and time the Speed
Force allows him to pull that off it
allows him to do that now in truth it's
really more of a plot device than
anything else but it's an intrinsic part
of the flash landscape and it's
something that flash readers that we as
we're just kind of take with a grain of
salt it allowed the stories to kind of
continue on their own but the issue here
is that in the middle of the fight we
end up having the new 52 Wally West who
is full on you know the flash now jump
into the skirmish against the future of
the future Barry Allen so that's really
kind of what we get here we get this
conflict between the new 52 Wally West
and the future Barry Allen now the
reason why this matters is because this
is them did be basically saying that all
villains end up engineering their own
demise in the sense that the entire
reason why this feature Barry Allen came
to the past but because of the fact that
Wally West had died of course he was
successful in essentially defeating
himself he was successful and pushing
himself to the point of almost complete
and total destruction but in the
aftermath of this ah the new 52 Wally
rust basically allows his speed sports
energy to be imbued into the current day
flash Barry Allen and the new VDT Wally
West dies in his step and so of course
you know with the modern day with the
modern-day Barry Allen regaining his
abilities he's basically just kind of
catapulted and lost in time now
ultimately he sent back you know in some
distant point it was a way for VIN day
to kind of focus on him outside of the
current event but what this does it kind
of wraps up the out-of-time situation it
leaves the modern-day version of Barry
Allen time-displaced and it leaves the
future flash in the modern day but again
it's really kind of one of these weird
things that I kind of held off on the
story for a little while just because of
the fact that messing with time could
cause all kinds of different problems
and it can be kind of kind of difficult
to explain in terms of you know how it
all how it all comes together but any
event if you guys are new here to
comment explain make sure you guys have
the sub button to become part of the Rob
north you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah guys we're
going to bring this video to an end and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you